assalamualaikum how you guys doing now
Andrew Tate has just been seen walking
into the courthouse with a book what is
this book that he's holding in his hand
okay by now everyone has figured out
what the book is the news media is
reporting on this book now before I go
further let's start with a person that
got to spend some time with Andrew Tate
I believe his name is Aiden he happens
to be a Jew
let's hear what he has to say about this
very same book that Andrew Tate is
holding in his hands walking into the
courthouse with like bro I'm Jewish and
the Quran is like there's a lot of Truth
to the Quran bro like a lot of stuff
that I really like like stand by like
the Quran is beautiful and I haven't
really studied the Holy Bible like that
but the Quran itself is just I don't
know it's just do you what do you think
so I don't I don't know nothing about
the Quran so educate me
today like a lot a lot bro that's I
watch videos on it and um I read up on
stuff and people discuss and break it
down because I don't really understand
you know now we're gonna do is just help
you give you just kind of a gist of what
this book actually is that Andrew Tate
keeps quoting on his Twitter feed and
now is confidently holding in his hand
walking in the courthouse with it for
the whole world to see now I want to
make a disclaimer before we get into
some really exciting things about the
book now I don't want to get into much
of the hypocrisy around this whole
circus I just want to make things clear
about the book what the book says what's
in the book and the book is clear on
these issues Islam is clear on these
issues on these issues that people keep
bringing up from when the man had hair
on his head or the majority of them were
way before Islam when he was an actually
an atheist because I used to be an
atheist and when you're an atheist you
believe that religion causes more
problems than it fixes and you realize
that religion is actually the cure for
most of the problems in the world and
godlessness is the problem in the world
so that is something I will apologize
for admit I was wrong about because I
was atheistic and now as a Muslim I
understand that's absolutely not the
case because all these things are
crystal clear there there are as we say
Haram prohibited forbidden in Islam and
as he grows in Islam submission to the
Creator not the creation step by step
he'll end up leaving off more and more
of these things that go against it now
let's look at some of these tweets that
Andrew take keeps quoting from the
verbatim words of God Almighty Allah
from the Quran that he's holding in his
hand this is a verse from the Quran they
plot and plan and Allah God Almighty two
plans but the best of planners is Allah
remember anytime you hear the word Allah
this is simply the name of the creator
that happens on Earth in the Arabic
Semitic language Allah does not burden
the soul beyond what it can bear
it's a beautiful beautiful verse no
matter what you're going through in life
God Almighty did not is not going to
test you with something that you cannot
bear
and he only tests you for you to go
ahead and learn to go ahead and be an
expiation for your sins they are much
there's much wisdom in these tests and
trials that we go through as human
beings especially as those who are
believers who believe in the pure
monotheism believe in the creator of the
heavens and the Earth as stated an
authentic saying of the last and final
message you're sent to mankind Prophet
Muhammad who said all the Affairs for
the believer are good this is only for
the believer
that when good comes to him he says
alhamdulillah I'll praise to the most
high
up above and when he's hit with a
Calamity like this one he's still saying
she's still saying alhamdulillah and
they're patient and this is good for him
another verse that he's tweeted truth
has come and falsehood has vanished
falsehood surely bound to vanish now
what's the main message about the
creator of the heavens and the Earth
that this was revealed in this Quran
which was revealed over a span of 23
years the book didn't just fall from the
sky it was revealed piecemeal to the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him over a span of 23 years and
compiled as we have it today it's a
living miracle if anyone is sincere
humble-hearted open-minded and they put
this book to the test seeking the
guidance from the creator of heavens and
earth wanting to know what the purpose
of life is why we're here why we're
created where are we going when we die
this Quran has all the answers it has
all the answers to the crucial questions
you should be asking most importantly
who is this Creator and it's and God
Almighty himself defines himself in the
Quran in this chapter
here we see that the crater is not his
creation he's not a man he doesn't have
sons and daughters he doesn't sleep eat
go to the bathroom he's unique and he is
absolutely one this is the pure
monotheism
and on that there's a moral code that is
established and from there the Quran
talks about Paradise the Hell Fire it
paints a clear Lucid description of
what's waiting for those those who
believe in one God live a morally
upright life when they make a mistake
they turn they repent to the crater of
alone alone they don't go into a
confession box they don't worship a
human being they don't worship
Messengers and Saints no they worship
one God directly alone that goes with
your very nature that makes sense
doesn't it and the Quran connects you
with the Hereafter gives you a blueprint
for this life helps you be the best
version of yourself in this life has
your eyes set on the prize which is
Jannah Paradise it shows you clearly how
to pass the test of this life and avoid
the Hellfire and all these things the
pornography webcam business
debauchery immorality all these things
if a person continues
consists with these things this is how
someone can end up in the Hellfire so no
muslim wants to be indulging in webcam
business in pornography drinking drugs
all these things that Society has
actually allowed but Islam is the
strictest on it and cuts this off this
evil from the root now you're probably
thinking how can I know you're telling
me this how but how can I be sure 100
percent that the Quran is from who
you're telling me it's not like all
these other man-made religions where
there's evidence in the Quran you want
scientific Miracles facts it's in the
Quran prophecies they're in the Quran
embryo and the Quran cannot be based on
scientific knowledge in the seventh
seventh century
foreign
could not have known these facts about
human development in the 7th Century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century these facts could
only have been revealed to Muhammad by
the one no one who knows all about us
things then when you read the book it
doesn't add up that a man living in a
desert peace and blessing to be upon a
problem Muhammad could have known these
things there is no way possible too many
to list in this short video and this is
just to entice you to form an
investigation to look closer into the
book that Andrew Tate is holding for the
whole world to see now I want you to
look at this little graph here and you
can see this illustrates all the
prophets and Messengers that God
Almighty Allah sent throughout time and
they all came with the same message
calling Humanity to worship one and only
one God that there's nothing worthy of
worship except that one God and you were
to obey the messengers that were sent at
that time they were calling people away
from paganism from idolatry from filing
your lust passions and desires and you
can see what happens when a person is
living on life a life away from God a
Godless life what happens to them they
indulge in all of these evil things now
and you see now where it can get you
that's why my brothers and sisters take
an example from this stay far away from
any of these things this is a great
example from our brother here who was an
atheist at that time he didn't know
Eddie better and this is the majority of
people young people this is what they're
doing porn is a multi-billion dollar
industry bigger than football basketball
all these Sports everything combined
together Islam cuts it off at the root
alcohol gambling all of these things
destroying homes destroying Society
Islam cuts it off from the root so
people like Andrew Tate and others who
are living at one time a Godless life
this is the kind of things that's
flaunted in front of them of course
they're going to explore and you see the
downhill spiral you see the kind of
things that can come back and haunt you
so those prophets and Messengers in the
diagram they all came with the same
message submit your will to the creator
of heavens and earth live a morally
upright life and at the end your prize
is Paradise Jannah and you you avoid the
Hellfire and although that led him to
the final messenger who came after Moses
who came after Jesus peace blessing be
upon him who was a messenger one of the
mightiest Messengers and the final
Messengers Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessed to be upon him and he bought the
living Miracle which is what Andrew Tate
was carrying with him into the
courthouse the Quran brothers and
sisters and Humanity at large I wanted
to just go ahead and give you something
that will entice you to look more into
the book I can go on but I wanted to
keep this short and I kind of in my
excitement I just went over the time so
let's cut it here if you guys want a
free copy of this very s this very book
the Quran
go ahead and visit thedishow.com and
we'll get it out to you
and we'll see you next time subscribe if
you haven't already hit that
notification Bell to get other videos
like this helping to you understand the
most misunderstood way of life yet the
fastest growing that brings peace
content and happiness to the hearts and
as a solution to all of these ills in
society all of these ills with the
webcam and the pornography and the
gambling and the alcohol and the
debauchery Islam solves it all to the
destruction of the family all of these
things Islam solves it all see you next
time until then peace be with you